manaus mitten im amazonas-regenwald hier
wütet das corona virus besonders stark
und es fehlt an allem auch an
medizinischen sauerstoff für die kranken
verzweifelt hoffen die menschen auf eine
füllung der sauerstoff flaschen für ihre
angehörigen jetzt gibt es dort auch
endlich eine impfung meine kollegin
annika rasch berichtet aus dem mutations
epizentrum im turm brasilien mit vollen
stränden aber auch mit vollen friedhöfen
denn die korona mutation p1 verbreitet
sich in brasilien
betroffen ist vor allem die
amazonasmetropole manaus die
intensivstation sind voll sauerstoff ist
mangelware
der explosionsartige anstieg der
infektionen hat in manaus zum kollaps
des gesundheitssystems geführt die virus
mutation soll besonders ansteckend sein
und verschärft die ohnehin angespannte
lage
doch nun ist ein neuer impfstoff
angekommen und viele menschen stürmen zu
den impfzentren mit dem auto sofort
bilden sich lange schlangen viele
menschen sind glücklich dass sie sich
jetzt impfen lassen können ich bin sehr
sehr glücklich über das impfmittel meine
mutter wurde gerade geimpft gott sei
dank sie wurde geimpft
ich habe zu gott gebetet jeden tag jetzt
bin ich sehr glücklich
mir geht es sehr gut und ich richte mich
an alle alten menschen dass sie sich
impfen lassen müssen
das ist wunderbar für brasilien das ist
eine erleichterung
das ist die eine sache die die pandemie
beenden kann und darauf haben wir lange
gewartet fensterscheibe runter und dann
gibt es einen peaks dahinter steht
bereits wie in einer waschstraße das
nächste auto
es geht schnell das ist die erste
möglichkeit für uns zu impfen wir haben
100 1000 impfdosen bekommen für unsere
alten menschen draußen wartet eine lange
menschenschlange darauf endlich geimpft
zu werden wir versuchen alle zu impfen
dann sind sie sicher das bedeutet viel
für die menschen in dieser pandemie
dieser impfstoff gibt der bevölkerung
hoffnung mann aus ist in einer schlimmen
situation viele menschen leiden viele
menschen sterben die menschen müssen zu
hause bleiben masken tragen und sich die
hände waschen
insgesamt sind brasilien bereits mehr
als 200.000 menschen mit oder an dem
corona virus gestorben auch in
deutschland wurde bereits eine neue
krone mutation aus brasilien
nachgewiesen
unsere reporterin annika rage ist seit
tagen für uns in brasilien unterwegs und
jetzt im epizentrum der krise in manaus
und dort steht sie auf einem friedhof
und ist uns jetzt auch zugeschaltet
hallo annika wie ist dort momentan die
situation also man kann hier tatsächlich
von einem kollaps einer apokalypse
sprechen weil man aus nicht mehr weiß
wohin mit seinen leichten bestehen wir
gerade auf einem teil des friedhofs des
größten fluss hier in der gegend und
allein in den letzten 20 tagen als man
kann sagen im januar wurden hier 380
menschen beerdigt die einfach nur corona
zum opfer gefallen sind also keinen
anderen krankheiten und wir waren jetzt
wir sind jetzt hier über drei stunden
und allein in den ersten zehn minuten
haben wir vier beerdigungen mit erlebnis
sowie eine massenabfertigung die leute
kommen kein abschied nehmen von ihren
verstorbenen angehörigen sondern sie
wurden wirklich einfach nur in die sehr
gut gepasst kann man wirklich sagen und
ein fachgebiet dann wird der sand drauf
beziehungsweise der lehmige boden
aufgeschüttet und dann ging es gleich
weiter für den bagger dann wird das
nächste grab ausgehoben also das sind
zustände die ich so noch nie erlebt habe
und die wirklich erschüttern ja
unglaublich brutale beschreibungen
unglaublich was du uns in diesem
friedhof schildert ist denn jetzt werden
sind ein beitrag gesehen die impfungen
sind da ist irgendwie besserung in
aussicht oder wird die situation ja
sogar noch schlimmer durch die
mutationen naja also sehr hat der
impfstoff ist hier schon eine große
hoffnung wir waren tatsächlich auf dem
flieger der ihr gestern den impfstoff
gebracht hat nach manaus von sao paulo
und der impfstoff ist eine hoffnung man
weiß aber jetzt aktuell noch nicht ob er
tatsächlich auch gegen die mutation
hilft die tatsächlich 50 prozent
ansteckender sein soll als der normale
corona die russin an führung
zeichen wonach oder präsident sagt aber
ihr könnt euch gerne impfen lassen aber
wer weiß auf ihr euch danach in
krokodile verwandelt also der präsident
sorgt dafür dass sich auch viele gegen
das impfen entscheiden
aber heute morgen haben wir das im
qualitäts- und ich muss sagen zweiten
leute am gejubelt alle drum herum die
krankenschwestern haben gejubelt und das
war schon sehr ergreifender moment dass
hier der im iran kommt wenn wir dich
inmitten dieser verzweifelten menschen
sehen annika was sagen die gesehen die
um irgendetwas welche wünsche welche
dringenden bitten haben sie an die ganze
welt in dieser region dort im
brasilianischen urwald
ich glaube hier große hoffnung ist jetzt
einfach dieser impfstoff das war
wirklich ein ganz wichtiger tag für die
bevölkerung hier
man muss aber auch sagen bis dezember
hier keiner masken getragen die leben
waren auch selbst an silvester gab es
partys mit bis zu 4000 menschen
die lage wurde einfach nicht ernst
genommen und jetzt merken sie müssen
sich impfen lassen die müssen auch auf
sauerstoff hoffen aus anderen ländern
der ihr per luftwaffe her transportiert
wird weil sonst ist die lage wirklich
aussichtslos annika wir haben es gerade
auch gesehen wie gehen die brasilianer
damit um auf der einen seite beschreibt
sie uns seit zehn minuten auf dem
friedhof schon vier beerdigung auf der
anderen seite sehen wir diese
schockierenden bilder von rio an der
copacabana wo buntes treiben am strand
herrscht mensch ein mensch wie gehen die
brasilianer derzeit mit dieser krise um
du bist ja seit einigen tagen jetzt im
land unterwegs
ja wir sind gestern die 2800 kilometer
von rio de janeiro je nach meiner
ausgereizt und das war wirklich eine
reise in eine andere welt also hier
merkt man die hoffnungslosigkeit mann
ist vom tod umgeben wenn man sieht
eigentlich nur die ganzen bestatter die
wagen kommen hier wirklich im
minutentakt an jetzt ist hier gerade
mittagspause für zwei stunden damit die
sich ausruhen können also hier wird
wirklich geschuftet um die show und
geschuftet
also es ist wirklich mal
kann es sich nicht vorstellen wenn man
vor in dieser friede janeiro war da sind
die zahlen auch sehr sehr hoch aber
daher stand doch noch mal wieder eine
ganz andere eine ganz andere stimmung
bei die leute immer noch an die strände
strömen und sagen na ja gut am strand
geht in einer frischen luft da kriegen
wir es vielleicht nicht ganz so schnell
ab annika uns beeindruckt seine
schilderungen von dem friedhof wo so
viele bestattungen gerade stattfinden
und vor allem die menschen seit es so
können kein abschied nehmen
kannst du uns mit der kamera ein
bisschen mitnehmen auf diesem friedhof
uns zeigen ja auch das ausmaß was dort
passiert gibt es denn vielleicht auch
angehörige geht zumindest nach den
beerdigungen versuchen die gräber zu
besuchen und abschied zu nehmen wir
sehen jetzt hier wieder umschwenken
kannst du uns ein bisschen beschreiben
die stimmung da auch das ausmaß was dort
auf diesem friedhof passiert kann ich
zwar nicht ganz so verdrehen weil hier
gerade regenzeit ist und es wirklich
schwer für den kameramann grad ist aber
also man es keine beerdigung im
klassischen sinne wie wir sie kennen das
man zeit hat am grab abschied zu nehmen
das ist wirklich eine massenabfertigung
als hätte man ein ticket gezogen und
dürfte jetzt seinen verwandten unter die
erde bringen
aber es ist wirklich also minuten takt
mit der einer runtergelassen dann wird
inter sand aufgeschüttet und dann ist
auch schon der nächste dran dass der
bagger war vorhin eigentlich die ganze
zeit am arbeiten und am schaufeln oder
schaufeln und wenn wir noch weiter nach
links gucken da sehen wir das weiße zelt
da sind die totengräber die den ganzen
tag geschuftet haben und die auch wir
haben mit ihnen gesprochen sie sagen sie
sind am ende psychisch aber auch
körperlich und den abend nutzten sie
dann um irgendwie zu schauen was die
nachrichten über irland eher sagen
sondern sie legen sich einfach nur noch
nach hause zu ihren familien in die
betten und müssen einfach abschalten
weil sie sagen dass es sonst nicht mehr
zu ertragen weil sie hier wirklich ihre
freunde oder bekannten
unsere familien selbst begraben müssen
beerdigungen im minutentakt unglaubliche
schilderungen vielen herzlichen dank an
unsere reporterin annika rasch in
brasilien derzeit danke wir sind bild
und wir liefert dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren